Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at Litestream.
It is a replicated
SQLite
with a whole bunch of really cool use
cases that we're gonna explore a little bit
today with its creator and vendor.
Before we get started, there is just a
little bit of housekeeping.
First,
please subscribe
to the channel and also remember to click
the thumb on the video.
This will do magic things with YouTube's algorithm,
which will help other people find this content,
which is
the goal here. Right? We wanna provide cloud
native
learning resources for those all to learn this
fast landscape together.
Also, we've got a Discord server available at
rockwood.chat.
It's a really great place to come and
ask questions, ask for new different episodes on
new technologies, and generally just chat Kubernetes, cloud
native, go, and a whole bunch of other
things. So come and join us. Great place
to hang out.
That's it. Boling bet done. Now we can
get started with this session. And for that,
I am joined by Ben Johnson. Ben Johnson
is the creator of Litestream.
Hey, mate. How is it going?
Hey. How are doing, man? Yeah. Very well.
Thank you.
Do you wanna just take a moment and
give us the TLDR on Ben Johnson?
Yeah.
I am a good developer. I've been doing
it for eight years now,
and I kind of always work in the
world of databases for that time.
And I wrote BoltDB. That's kind of another
open source project I've done in the past.
Just kind of a key value store that
got pretty popular. It's actually in Kubernetes itself
as part of etcd.
And then, I don't know, just played around
with a bunch of different open source projects
over the years. And then one thing that
I've always kind of loved was just like
that, like, embedded databases. Like, they're just
they're so easy to use, like, kinda, like,
just be up and running. There's not a
lot of dependency issues. They're easy to debug
typically, but I wanted kinda, like, SQL support.
But I also wanted to kinda make it
kinda more robust and, like, production ready. So
that's kinda how I came down the the
Litestream path. So,
yeah, I've been working on Litestream for the
last
it's kind of been going on since the
last maybe year or two. Just trying to
figure out the ins and outs of SQLite
and figuring out how you can get this
all to kinda work in different iterations and
just trying to simplify it as much as
possible.
Nice.
Does it take a special kind of person
to work in databases? Like, these now worked
on numerous that I'm aware of. And, like,
these must be, like, the hardest thing in
the world to be working on. Like, do
you just like pain? Is that it?
Yeah. I think it's just masochism, really.
It's weird it's kind of a weird thing.
Like, I have people that I work with
that work in databases.
They always say, like, I am going back
to doing just, web apps. Like, I'm doing
something simple next time, and we always kinda
come back to databases.
But, like, it's a you think it's really
difficult, but it it's actually, like,
it's like a smaller problem space. Like, typically,
you only work at, you know, you work
with bytes and, like, it's very low level.
Whereas, you know, I used to work in,
like, web apps and front ends, and that's
all, like, I got four different browsers to
work in and different, you know, kind of
a things that, you know, CSS problems. Like,
I get in CSS now and I just
I get lost. So it's one of those
things that it seems really difficult from the
outside, but it just depends on where you're
coming from really. I guess it all comes
down to where you wanna focus your expertise
and your domains and like, I guess every
other domain is gonna appear challenging. I suffer
the same. Like, I tried to write CSS
a whole bunch of times. I've rewritten my
blog 14,000 times in the last month and
CSS is always trips me up. It's hard.
But Yeah. Yeah. So it's it's cool that
you're always working on databases. Maybe you can
kind of then tell us what drew you
to to SQLite.
Sure. Yeah.
I think as far as like, SQLite's kinda
known for just being super rock hard, stable.
Like, they put it in airplanes. They put
it in all kinds of devices, and it
just kinda works everywhere.
The team behind it is just super chill
and laid back. They're not always out, you
know, on social media, like, touting how amazing
they are and whatever stuff. It's kinda like
they just you know, I feel like,
like, people that are just, like, really database
nerds, like
or
they don't do all the marketing fluff. I
feel like I feel like that's kind of
a a good sign.
So as far as SQLite, like, it's it's
one of the few embedded databases that just
kind of is ubiquitous
and is has SQL support, like, strong SQL
support.
So you can do a lot of things
you can do in something like Postgres where
you get JSON support, you get,
like, CTEs,
like the recursive queries you can do in
there,
windowing. You get all kinds of functionality.
It's
kinda surprising for just a single small embedded
database.
That's kinda what drew me there.
Yeah. I think it was maybe shortly after
your livestream announcement. I it it kinda got
me thinking, like, I've never considered
and I think it's just my own ex
the way that I've worked with SQLite over
the years, it's always been used for
testing
environments and never never really considered chipping it
to prod. And I threw the question to
Twitter. I mean, like, when when I say
SQLite, what do you think of? Like, production,
testing,
embeddings, and stuff like that. And there were
a lot of production SQLite people that were
like, yeah. Like, definitely. And I I think
it was just my own mindset just wasn't
there and now I'm having to reevaluate that.
So is that something Yeah. That you do
yourself or receive other people that SQLite has
a strong contender for a production database.
Yeah. Honestly, I'm always surprised by how many
people out there actually use it.
And just like and it's just running stuff
all over the world.
And,
you know, there's there's kind of a range
of different applications even before Lightstream that you
could use SQLite for a production database. Like,
if you can do, you know, hourly or
daily backups with your data and, like, that
window of data loss isn't
gonna tank your company or your organization or
whatever you're doing, like, that's that's a great
approach. Just a simple replication.
There's simple simple backups.
So I think there's a lot of ways
you can use it and still get a
lot out of it. And it just it
reduces a lot of the ops overhead. So
if you're not an ops person, like, I'm
not a big ops person,
I think it goes a long way for
that too.
Okay. So maybe we can get a pivot
over to Litestream then. And, like, what does
Litestream bring to the SQLite world?
Sure. Yeah.
So
Litestream, it's a single file on your data
on your disk.
And if you're running your application and then
it just dies suddenly, your disks crash,
and you lose all your data, that sucks,
and, you know, hopefully, you have a backup.
But the problem with, you know, historical backup
solutions for SQLite is they are kind of
a big snapshot.
So you have to run them every hour,
every day, something like that. So you get
this huge window of data loss that, you
know, doesn't work for a lot of people.
So what LightStream does is it kind of
takes the changes that are written to
to SQLite
and then batches them up every second and
ship ships them up to s three or
some other replica.
So that means So it's a
go ahead. I see where it goes. So
does does that mean then if I'm running
Litestream against my SQL database that
in an ideal world, I'm only ever gonna
lose one second in the event that my
application crashes or the failed system has a
corruption or everything like that.
Yeah. So, ideally, it's one second of data
loss. You also get other benefits too where
if you did a drop table on your
or, you know, a bunch of drop tables
on your database and lost a bunch of
data, it will corrupt it somehow just through,
like, easier error.
You can actually replay the database back into
a previous point in time so you can
kind of recover from those scene or scenarios
as well.
Ah, I I So you get a multiple
level. Oh, go ahead.
I I had no idea that point in
time was a was an option when you
hook up Litestream. I I guess that makes
a lot of sense. Right? I think you've
got some slides to talk about how this
actually works under the hood. Do you wanna
pop them up and we can Sure. Yeah.
Can pop those up. Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, there we go. Indeed.
Cool. Can you see my screen now? Yeah.
Yep. You are live. Go for a bit.
Cool. Awesome. So you got Litestream.
So you I'm sorry. Streaming, like, replication for
SQLite.
And just kinda this is how SQLite works
internally mostly, and then you can kinda see
how Litestream
kind of attaches onto that.
So SQLite and, honestly, like most databases honestly,
it's kinda ridiculous when you hear comparisons of,
like, SQLite to, like, maybe MySQL's faster or
Postgres is faster. Like, they're all gonna be
just b trees storage on your disk. Like,
they're mostly kind of structured the same. They
have a couple different features, but you're not
gonna get, like, wildly different performance from SQLite
versus Postgres or whatnot.
So this is what a table kinda looks
like on disk
or kinda looks like logically.
You have kind of a root node and
then it branches out. And then at the
very bottom, you have leaf nodes, which is
where your actual data is stored. But all
these different
parts of your data or chunks of data
are all stored in these pages, which are
usually about four kilobytes,
and they're structured as a a b tree.
So what happens this is kind of a
busy slide here. So the on the right
side, there's the logical rep sorry, representation
where you have this tree
of how your your data is stored on
disk,
but that actually gets stored as just a
sequential
list of pages, and they kind of reference
each other, but they're all these four kilobyte
blocks. That's kind of the important thing to
know, and they're all stored in this a
single database file.
So when you make a change to SQLite,
it has a couple different modes it can
work in. Lightstream only works when you're in
a SQLite to wall mode, which is usually
the kind of recommended one to use anyway.
Instead of overwriting the page on disk, it'll
actually write it it'll append it to another
file called the write ahead log,
and that write ahead log actually kind of
just
it references to the pages on the database
file. So in this example, we have a
database file that has pages zero through eight.
And then if we make a change to
something on page three, it'll copy or it
kinda make it'll write the whole page three
to the wall file. And then we make
a change to page one, and yes. You
see now you can't see my cursor. So
it makes a change to page one, it'll
pin that on. And then if it makes
another page change to page three, it'll pin
that on. So it kinda has this
this layering of the wall file on top
of the database file kind of while it's
running. Not sure if that makes sense. That's
kinda how a lot of databases work.
So,
eventually,
you know, this wall file gets bigger and
bigger, and it'll do something called checkpointing, where
checkpointing moves all those pages back into the
main database file and overwrites everything for all
those change pages.
And
then it'll kinda clear out that those pages
on the wall file,
and it'll restart from the beginning. So it's
it's basically kinda like a circular buffer where
it'll kinda fill it up and then restart
from the beginning and just kinda keep going
in a circle.
So
what,
Litestream does is we kind of unroll those
restarts of the wall file.
So your first wall file gets written out,
and when it restarts,
Litestream
basically is copying those wall pages to a
kind of station area.
And then once it restarts, it'll start a
new wall file with those new pages. So
it kind of incrementally keeps track of all
new rights to the wall even though that
the wall kind of gets restarted and reused.
So then we have the staging area with
Litestream,
and we start shipping out those
chunks of the wall out to either an
s three buckets. We can do Azure. We
can do Google Cloud Storage.
We can do you do NFS over, like,
a mount. You can do SFTP
and yeah. Yeah. All kinds of different little
replica destinations you can go to.
And, effectively, once you ship them out there,
if you wanna recreate
the state of your database, we just pull
down a snapshot, which is kind of your
whole database at a certain point in time,
and then replay all the wall pages that
occurred after that up to a certain point
in time.
So that's kind of the
the basics of how that works. Does that
make sense? It does make sense. Yeah.
So I know it gets a little technical
and nerdy with the
some of database pages and terminology, but
kinda really, the underlying structure is just kind
of this append only
set of data that Litestream keeps track of.
It's all those wall page changes.
So it kinda remain I don't know if
you're familiar with event sourcing, but it's a
really cool architecture that I've experimented with over
the years, and it kinda feels like that.
I got I never really correlated that to
write ahead logs in general, but maybe that
is a Yeah. I mean analogy?
Yeah. That's a decent analogy. I haven't actually
built anything with event sourcing, but I know
what you're talking about.
I kinda think of it also, like, Kafka
is pretty similar where it has this kind
of append only set of events.
You can replay all those events and get
the same final
state. So, yeah, very similar.
So but look. Based on what you just
showed, is there a rig?
I mean, Litestream is doing really what SQLite
is doing as well, which is, you know,
s right into the wall and then doing
the checkpoints and the snapshotting.
Does Litestream just forgo the
the checkpoints and always stores the different walls
in the different iterations or do you actually
merge them at some point? I'm wondering how
far back in time does the Justin, the
point in time recovery go with Litestream.
So they should take care that one. Yeah.
No. That's that's great. Yeah. So
what Litestream does is it has kind of
a retention policy on it. So by default,
it's about twenty four hours, and then it'll
do a new snapshot and kind of start
from there with the wall again.
And you can configure that snapshot more often,
but and then retain longer. So if you
want to retain,
you know, for seven days and maybe do
a snapshot every day or every hour, you
could do that.
So your your point in time recovery is
however long that retention period is. Okay. And,
you know, if you have stuff like s
three, like, three,
the way that AWS really makes money is
kind of when you download files, but for
replication, you really just upload files.
So it's actually super cheap to to replicate
up to s three, which is great.
Yeah.
Plus it supports is that any s three
compatible API, or is that like a a
subset that you've kind of just tested that
against?
So it's any s three compatible API.
The only
caveat I would say is that it did
not work on Google Cloud Storage, which has
a compatible API because it wasn't that compatible.
But we had a native support on the
last version. So it's works on there in
Azure as well.
Awesome. Alright. Alright. Your question is, can you
say more about why Litestream unrolls the wall
pages at checkpoint time?
Wouldn't you just need the most recent wall
pages plus a snapshot to replay or build
the database?
That makes sense to you? Well,
I know think. So
it's
would you only need the most recent wall
pages plus a snapshot to replay it? So
it it doesn't keep yeah. You could keep
a unique set of pages,
but I think that'd be difficult to track
over time.
Kind of the doing the unroll and pushing
up to s three makes everything immutable, which
kinda simplifies a lot of pieces too. We're
not trying to merge merge pages together.
If I understand your question correctly, you could
technically merge
those, but but, yeah, it could be for
future
feature.
Alright. Nice. Thank you.
So is it fair to say then that
the recovery time of Litestream is is pretty
fast depending on the size of your database,
of course? I'm assuming that you're just pulling
down
the snapshot, the wall, replaying it, and then
your application is is up and running again.
Right?
Yeah. So it definitely yeah. It definitely depends
on kind of your your length of time
between from your snapshot to where you wanna
replay to and how many pages you have.
It does pull down the the individual files
in parallel.
So it tries to fill up the pipe,
you know, your your bandwidth,
getting those down. And then the actual replays
of the walls is pretty fast depending on
your disk, but it's it's literally just copying
four k pages
from one file to another. So it's nothing
it's nothing too crazy.
Nice. And I I like I hadn't really
thought about the drop table scenario. I mean,
I think we've all done it at some
point in our careers, I would imagine. But
been able to have that point in time
recovery to revert that
would be
very, cool. Almost the same performance. I wish
wish I'd had that
at various points in my career. So
awesome.
Yeah.
Alright. Anything else you wanna share on Litestream
before we get hands on? Did we did
we touch on all the the major bits
there?
I would say that let's see. That's all
the major bits. One thing I would say
as far as some kind of some feature
work that's kind of coming up,
there's stuff we're looking at around doing live
replications. You can have multiple read
read replicas. So if you wanna start growing
out your kind of a cluster of SQL
like applications,
you can have you can scale your reads
for that. There's, you know, work being done
around looking at encryption, so you could replicate
up to an untrusted
data server, replicate destination,
things like that. So there's a lot of
cool stuff coming.
Awesome.
Alright. I believe you've got a a Slack
channel and stuff as well, so we can
drop links to that in the chat and
people can Oh, yeah. Get involved as well.
Let me pull up my my screen share
just now. So this is the Litestream homepage.
It is available at litestream.io.
And today, we're just gonna kinda
run through the
getting started guide to give you all of
idea
of how you can start using Litestream for
yourself. If you do have any questions, feel
free to drop them into the comments and
we will do our best to get them
answered.
Now you've already watched me do this once
before. You said that was a lot of
fun. Right?
You did a great job. I was impressed.
You got a q three s up.
Yeah. It was good fun. I really enjoyed
working on that. Working on that.
I'm gonna jump ahead first and just get
a manual running and a Docker container. So
this is the s g compatibility manual.
We can just run locally without ever having
to speak to Amazon s three, which I
am a Mhmm. Big fan of.
Really cool software.
I was used to use the AWS s
three for the getting started,
and just it was very confusing to anyone
that's never set up, you know, IAM accounts
and
AWS buckets and all that stuff. So
It's definitely one of big challenges.
I mean, I have set up IAM buckets
and roles and groups and all this before,
but and it's still complicated.
Just
Yeah. Oh, yeah. You do one wrong thing
and you just
gotta Yeah. See what happened now. Figure out
what you did. Super
painful. Yeah. Yeah. I do not recommend it.
Oh,
Was this here last time? I don't remember
a tap. Oh, yeah. Yep. Go tap on
there now.
Fancy. Alright. Let's split this terminal.
I don't even I'm obviously just gonna be
learning stuff today. I don't know you could
do brew install and then the tap and
then the package name. Does that automatically do
the brew tap for me?
Yeah. It automatically hooks it up. I can't
remember who told me about that, but, yeah,
I used to have the whole instruction of,
like, yeah, the tab and you do this
and update through, but, yeah, it's great. Just
one line. Awesome.
Yeah.
As long as I keep learning stuff with
this, I'm a happy person.
Oh,
where is all? Is this all is this
compiling
it from source?
Or is this just because I break my
machine last week and it now wants me
to do loads of silly stuff that I
haven't done in a while? Let's find out.
Yeah. It shouldn't be that's weird. It shouldn't
be
building anything. It should just be pulling down
the binary.
Yeah. Oh, it's just my machine.
I I said this to you prior, but
I was Yeah. Share
my stupidity with the audience. It's that I
installed the Mac OS 12
really early developer beta last week and nothing
on my machine worked and I had to
revert everything
back to the start. So, yeah, there's gonna
be loads of these little things over the
next couple of weeks, I would imagine. Yeah.
I guess I could always just grab the
from
get With a fast connection at least. That's
good.
I do. I got fiber with my ISP
recently and it's Nice. Pretty solid.
Yeah. I'll grab the binary just now.
Yeah. That works.
Actually, take out the dot io at the
top. Yep. You're On the
yeah.
We got a bunch of different
support for different operating systems and architectures too.
So we have
You feeling brave while I go with alpha?
No. No. Don't do that.
Or because some refactoring going on for dot
four, but
let's yeah. That's fine. I mean, I'm ready.
For a lot.
Yeah. We got, yeah, Mac, Linux. We got
Windows support on there, OpenBSD.
We do a bunch of different ARM
chip versions too. So you can go all
the way down to
what do they call it? Raspberry Pi zeros.
Yeah. Those tiny little $5 ones. You can
run Litestream on there if you want.
That's pretty nice. Okay. Let's see. What did
I grab there? Litestream,
zip,
Alright. There we go. I'll just let x
code do its thing in the background.
Okay.
And I'll get the brew tap version another
day. But it's nice that they exist. I
don't know if I missed that or I've
just forgotten that I used that. I'm pretty
sure I downloaded the binary last thing, but
brew tap should definitely Yeah. Think it's been
there for a little while.
Especially with the Linux support now, which I
haven't used a great deal
because I'm an arch user, so I use
arch for pretty much everything. But for real
analysis, it's pretty cool.
Alright. Litestream.
We've got Menio.
We've got our credentials without any IAM policies,
Menio admin and Menio admin. But I think
we are probably good to get started. Seven
minutes now. That was a minute a second
ago.
Alright. Okay.
So
we should be able to browse to menu
on the web interface.
I guess I'll just need to create a
bucket.
Yep. That's all I gotta do.
I will say the interface always throws me
off. I'm always looking everywhere but the lower
right hand corner.
Yes.
It's done that to me a few times.
Alright. I'll just call this bucket Litestream.
There we go. We've a bucket. Yeah. We've
got a comment from Russell in the chat
saying, kill product database backup save careers.
That indeed is true.
Also, hi to Jack Lindsay and some way
earlier.
Oh, yeah. We gotta we gotta wait to
okay. So we've created our bucket and now
we wanna create a SQL lite database.
Do you have any tips for the people
watching on tooling at you guys for working
with SQLite, or do just keep it pretty
generic with the CLI?
You know, I keep it pretty generic. We
do have, like, a tips and caveat section
inside of the Litestream website that gives some
tips for
just running it with different settings and how
they can kind of affect and help things
just from more of an application development standpoint
more than anything with Litestream.
But for the most part, it just kinda
works, especially if you're if you're in wall
mode.
That helps a ton. And you could create,
like, concurrency, like, reconurrency
with that. So
I've gotten just crazy performance, honestly, with just
writing I write everything Go, like web apps
and everything. Yeah.
Go web apps with SQLite back end. You
just you have no latency, like, per query
latency.
So I typically you know, I can run
several queries, render HTML,
and you get it all back in, you
know, fifty microseconds. So it's pretty snappy.
Yeah. I guess because of it's in wall
mode. Right? Ever does that mean everything runs
in memory to a certain degree, you're never
actually really touching the desk until snapshot?
Well, I mean, naturally get a lot of
memory stuff anyway. It has a bit of
a cache inside of SQLite. I think it
uses a map as well,
so you kinda get the OS page cache
as well.
But the wall stuff is
it it basically has different versions of your
data. You know, there's different pages, and I
have different versions. So, you know, a transaction
started,
you know, at first or at one point
in time has its own view of the
database, and another one can start later on
before that other one finishes and get a
different, you know, snapshot of the database. So
it really helps with that.
I
guess if you also throw some NVMe discs
on this, it's probably gonna give you a
nice performance. That can't hurt. Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Let's export
variables.
Yeah. Also, also just to with the stuff
you're doing right now Yeah. You know, we're
just creating a database that has a list
of fruits in there.
And we basically wanna replicate this database out
to Litestream, and you can kinda see
how quickly it will give you the the
new version of that just kind of
in the background. You don't have really even
have to think about it, and then you
can kind of restore that easily as well.
Yeah. So we've just got a simple create
table and set a couple of through it.
I don't can I just drop out of
this now? Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. So we've got that.
Alright. Actually And there's a DB.
You see I I sensed that Yeah. In
your voice.
Oh, yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Stay in the the
database there.
One thing
is you can I mean, it should be
fine, actually, but you're gonna have to have
multiple windows running to kinda really see it?
How do I use the database?
I think
you you hit
command d. I think it'll exit you out.
So can I just select Control? Sorry. Control
d. Alright. Okay. Yeah. I just Oh, sorry.
Was sorry. I see what you're saying. There's
only one database SQLite. Because it's SQLite, and
it's a fail. I'd alright. Okay. Mhmm. I
will say one other nice thing about SQLite
that people don't think about is you can
get, like, actual tenant isolation.
Like, you can put a tenant per database
file, and that works totally fine. So there's
just there's a lot of cool little things
you can do that you wouldn't really think
of naturally, I would say.
Alright.
Let's get one more of these running
and we copy oh, no. I did copy
something, but I've lost it. Oh, yeah. The
token. Okay. Alright. Yes. Yeah.
Okay. So this is our Litestream. Let me
zoom in on that a bit more. Our
Litestream command.
We just call replicating. L.
You're missing the l at the beginning. There
you Just wanna make sure you copy the
whole thing. I I see. I think it's
little copy all buttons on the docs. It's
killing me.
Those really handy. Definitely.
Yeah. I always say that to everyone I
have on this show. Every time there's a
mistake, I guarantee you it is my fault
for some reason or not.
Oh, man. See, one of the other things
that I really do on the show that
I'm starting to hate myself for is that
I use temp directories for everything
and now I'm no longer in a temp
directory.
Now I can either download Litestream again or
if very quickly
that find it.
Yeah. This is one of those moments where
I need to stop using temp directory. Right.
There
we go.
Right. We still got our fruits.
I should still have my export. I also
use pair directory history, which I love and
then hate on the stream as well. So
Alright.
I'm just gonna type this from memory because
it's so intuitive and easy to use. But
replicate
through it dot dbs3
local host
three So we're actually gonna put
almost Litestream
dot local host. So you're gonna put the
bucket name before local host and dot.
You sure?
I don't think so. I could be wrong.
I think you're wrong. I know you're the
author of the software, but I'm just gonna
go out there and and say, I think
you're wrong.
Damn it.
So is that something Yeah. So there's two
parts. There's the what was that?
Go ahead. I mean, I've never seen, like,
wildcard
DNS aliases in that way for local host.
Is that a thing?
Yeah. I mean, we're just using the URL
kind of to
pull all the data together, kind of all
the the connection info together. It's really more
of a connection string than anything.
And, typically, it makes probably more sense when
you have, like, an actual s three bucket
where the s three buckets are typically referenced
as s three colon slash slash and then
just the name of the bucket.
So
it's a little bit hacky for Mineo, to
be honest.
Well, that
looks
successful. Looks yeah.
So it starts off I'm give you oh,
go ahead. No. It's okay. Go for it,
man.
Yeah. So it starts off to saying it's
replicating
and kinda gives you the database or databases
that you're replicating,
where they're going to, and then how often
it's gonna sync. So by default, it syncs
every one second.
And
the whole there's some talk about generation in
here. A generation is just basically when you
have a snapshot and then kind of a
contiguous
set of of wall pages after that. So
you can get in a situation where, say,
you you stop
your Litestream process,
your application keeps going and then you start
it back up again,
your your other process may have already checkpointed
that data and kind of gotten rid of
it and Litestream would have lost its place.
And Litestream will just detect that automatically, and
generations are just kind of where it can
kind of kinda start over. It'll restart re
snapshot and then just keep replicating from there.
Very cool.
So
let just go back to we've got our
manual browser open. So I just wanna kinda
see Mhmm.
See the thing.
There's the generations you were kinda talking about.
And we've got our snapshot. Yeah. We've got
our right ahead log.
So Mhmm.
I mean, we're we're pretty happy that this
is working. Alright? So Yeah. So far, so
good. If I insert more groups, we're gonna
see a bit of activity on the Litestream
side. Is that pushing more stuff? No.
It's not it doesn't log excessively. It typically
logs in kind of major events, you know,
like snapshots and then errors. Right. So it
tries to keep the log relatively light. Otherwise,
you probably get a lot of activity.
So but and it probably would be worth
adding an option to make it more verbose.
Well, I am going to
oh, my computer is not happy with me
today at all. There we go. You jumping
back?
I should just if I could choose Linux
for streaming, I totally would. Things just work
on Linux. So I never thought I'd say
that. But
alright. Let's add. Everyone agrees with you on
that.
No. Definitely not.
Peach. What color is a peach? Peach color?
Yeah.
Yeah. That sounds good. Like peach peach.
Okay. So
what is the the best way,
you know, for people that are playing with
livestream?
You've mentioned that there's not maybe a lot
of logging coming out here. Like, is there
any way for them to just check that
the replication is is happy and working? Or
if there's no errors, is that thumbs up?
You're good to go. Go have a beer
late. Yeah. So generally thumbs up if there's
nothing going on in there. It's it's kind
of come like a constant loop that's running.
That's
that's checking and kind of uploading stuff. One
thing you can do, there is a
some stuff from the
actually, if you jump in, I guess, another
window, I if you got room for one
more.
Always got room for more terminals.
There you go.
And then kinda have to go back at
the same temp directory that you were before.
Yep.
Alright. Cool.
So, yeah, if you just type Litestream and
hit enter, it'll show you some commands.
So, yeah, if you you
can so yeah. It's a little bit small,
but so there's kind of three basic commands
outside of so there's replicate and restore, which
is where you kind of push out your
data, and then restore brings it back and
kinda recreates it.
The other ones are databases,
generations, and snapshots.
Databases will list the databases you have if
you're using a config file or just kinda
more the recommended format, you know, just kind
of playing around with it.
And then generations
generation snapshots and wall
are the other ones that kinda see the
state of your actual replica information.
So if you do Litestream
generations
and then put in the name of your
database or just a local path there,
Yeah. Hit enter.
Oh, shoot. It's the
put in the Rawkode URL.
So the s3colon
slash slash.
Alright. Relate stream. And then Litestream. Yeah. Local
post 9,000.
And slide. Yep. Like that.
I don't know why it's taking so long.
It usually is pretty snappy.
Oh, that's because you don't have
credentials in there. That's right.
There you go.
There we go. Okay. So that'll show the
lag on there. So right now, it's two
minutes and nineteen seconds, which is the last
time you put that's when you put the
peach in peach bro in there. But if
you add another fruit in there and then
run
your generations command again,
then that lag should drop.
I mean, I'm feeling pressure.
Pineapple.
There we go.
And
And, actually, if you before you do that,
if you run it, you can run that
generations command on a watch if you wanna
see it
return immediately.
And you can even go pretty pretty low.
Oh, there you go.
Again.
Always gonna happen. My fault for not
For for breaking my computer. I'm gonna I'm
gonna honestly, I'm gonna That's right. Day for
the next month. I'm just always gonna think
that one little thing that never worked.
Yeah. No. I was happy with pineapple as
my choice there too.
What's your thoughts on pineapple on a pizza,
Ben? People wanna know. I know. That's sacrilege.
You know, I do cheese pizza. Like, I'm
vegetarian so I don't do meat, but
I'm pretty simple, to be honest.
Alright. Okay.
Cheese pizza. Alright. So Do you what's that?
Cheese pizza is oh, cheese. Alright.
Yeah.
So if you enter that in there, then
pretty quickly, it should
should lag that down. So now it's down
to, you know, one second, two seconds.
So that's it's grabbing the kind of the
last timing or time out of the wall
file that's up there
on menu.
Alright. I'm gonna pick the color first and
then try to think of it through.
Okay. Red. Damn it. It's what I do.
Cherry?
Cherry. Good catch.
It's probably fair. It's pretty quick. Like, I
mean No. Yeah. It's snappy. Yeah.
It's usually about a one second delay, so
you'll usually see it sub steps. I'm curious.
Is is that one second,
you know
is is that arbitrary? Is that something that
you've picked as part of the code? I
mean, could people get that lower if they
wanted, or is that just a sensible default?
Like
Yeah. There's kind of a trade off
between
kind of the time to push out. It's
not even a really performance issue for Litestream
because it can usually check pretty quickly about
the underlying data. You could drop it lower.
Usually, the issue is that you get charged,
I think, it's, $5.10
thousandths of a a cent or something like
that every time you do a post up
to s three Mhmm. Which is pretty cheap.
And if you're running just a constant stream
of rights to your database,
then dropping it below one second, you'd start
getting expensive.
It used to actually be ten seconds was
the default, but people usually don't have a
constant stream of
of rights to the database. So it seemed
like a sensible default dropping down to one.
And is that configurable if I wanted that
on a minute or even ten minutes or
whatever? Yeah. Yeah. Yep. That all that totally
works. Nice.
And that'll actually kind of stop your
it'll cut off your wall and kinda restart
it automatically every minute so you can get
that. Like, your your point in time
recovery
is kinda determined by that kind of how
often it
restarts that wall
just because you can only have a certain
granularity to
replay into.
Okay.
I also noticed If that makes any sense.
Yeah.
I think so. I'm getting curious, like, the
SQLite commands that I executed were just
there was nothing that told it to use
the wall. So is that something you get
for default? Or because you mentioned I think
you said at the start, like, it had
to be enabled that way. Can you maybe
elaborate on that?
Sure. Yeah. So, like, stream auto, think we'll
put it into wall mode if it's not
in the wall mode,
which was a decision I was kinda back
and forth on.
But, honestly, most like, it's usually the recommended
mode to run-in with a few exceptions. It's
usually if you have like, lot of people
will use lights or SQL lights as kind
of a file format. So because it stays
in a single file. If you really want
it to just be that single file, then
you can use their other journaling modes. But
wall will have kind of two separate files
that'll work with, but it just it provides
all the concurrency
support. It's way faster. There's a lot of
there's a lot of big benefits to it.
So it just automatically triggers it into wall
mode. And then that that persists across
processes.
Yeah.
So that means if I have
you know, an application that's been using SQLite
for
for years,
I don't really need to compare or do
anything. Like, when Litestream kicks in, it's just
gonna go, hey. You should be in wall
mode now, and it does the same thing.
Yeah. Yeah. And I've actually seen I've seen
a lot of people actually just put this
onto
all kinds of different
app like, existing applications without that application knowing
anything about it. So I've seen, like, ghost
blogs.
I've seen a bunch of people do that.
I think I just saw somebody do it
with WordPress. You know, they can use the
SQLite version, and it just kicks in. They've
deployed in, like, a little Docker container and
everything.
So it's kinda cool. Some people actually run
this. Like, I usually recommend running with a
persistent disk just to get, you know, add
additional durability
guarantees.
But some people run Litestream with no just
an ephemeral disk, and they just, you know,
go crazy, and it seems to work. So
I'm I'm not that brave.
Yeah. Lots of stuff to experiment with there.
I've already got a few ideas from my
head. Like, oh, I could just, a a
RAM disk and go a bit crazy with
that. But
No. Yeah. I mean, you can if you
want. I mean, again, there's, kind of that
window data loss
where if you had a persistent disk,
it would, you know, be fine. I mean,
technically, Litestream will flush out changes,
when it powers down or when it shuts
down cleanly. Mhmm. So, generally, it should've worked
actually to run on an ephemeral disk, but
I'm just super paranoid.
So we got one more question. We've got
a question on the chat. We'll tack on
a second, but something else popped in my
head and if I don't ask it now,
I forget. But
let's say I've got my application, it's using
SQLite,
I add Litestream, it does some stuff, I
shut down Litestream, forget to start it, erase
some data to my SQLite, and then restart
Litestream.
Is Litestream okay with that? Yeah.
That'll be great. It'll just pick up where
it it'll send it'll notice that the the
walls changed,
you know, especially if it's been running long
enough and enough rights go through.
Then it'll sense that, you know, that wall
is kinda restarted and it needs to start
a new generation.
Now it'll just pick that up automatically.
And it doesn't it cleans out the old
generations based on retention. So you actually still
have that old version of your data even
though there's kind of that went that gap
of
time where Litestream wasn't replicating up.
Nice. I like that a lot. Okay. Let's
tackle Riel's question then,
which I promise you I've not paid anyone
to ask. But Rio is asking, would this
work for SQL lite in case yes?
It was a fantastic question. It is a
fantastic question. Do you wanna tackle that? I'll
let you answer that one. Alright. Okay. No.
I think I think you're the expert on
this
I actually
Rio spent
a good few hours experiment with just that.
One of my fascinations at the moment is
cluster API, which uses Kubernetes in a weird
way, essentially like a database and KCS
with SQLite and Kane.
I thought it would be a really cool
way to hook Litestream up to that replicate
s three. So hopefully, the exact same use
case that you're talking about. And the answer
is yes. It worked perfectly. I didn't even
need to do anything other than read the
documentation,
run Litestream, and it just worked. I have
had cluster API running for days. I've shut
down the machines, spun it back up
and things just worked. So that is a
100% yes on KTS and Litestream.
Okay. Let's jump back over to our CLI.
We don't have too long left, so we'll
run through just a couple more things, I
think.
Sure.
I I guess you can run through the
restore. That probably makes sense. Yes.
Do you wanna cover anything else on these
subcommands? Because we were Yeah. Sure.
Sure.
Yeah. I mean, the snapshots in the wall
are just gonna list out the snap like,
the little snapshot up regularly,
just the full database at a certain point
in time. And then the wall, you know,
you can see all the little individual files
that have been pushed up. But, generally, you
only need those for
debugging if you have issues or just kinda
wanna see some stats. But
nine times out of 10, you're really looking
at restore and replicate
and then running generations if you just wanna
see the lag of
replication.
Okay. So let's do a restore. I'm assuming
the the getting started guide is probably going
there anyway. Right? So yeah. Yeah.
Restore. So
why don't we
I can just close Litestream,
delete the Fritz DB, and then trigger a
restore.
Just looking So you have to keep Lightstream
what's that? Keep keep Lightstream running
and then
run the restore on a separate window.
Is that what you're saying?
No. I was gonna delete the first dot
DB and then run our restore to pull
it back down. Are you suggesting something else?
I always see what you're saying. I was
suggesting restoring it to a different location.
Ah.
Okay.
Alright. Let's do it your way.
So we're gonna do a restore
oh, yeah. We've got this output flag, so
we can say,
fruits two dot d b.
My very imaginative naming.
And then
stream
local host. I mean,
this is
I'm confused. I always we we I need
to work this.
Litestream.local
host. I know I'm coming back to this,
but it's just it's not sitting right in
my head.
Is that something Litestream is doing to work
out the bucket name or is that actually
something that is a convention on computers? Because
I'm a little bit shocked. No. No. It's
no. It's just it's kind of a hacky
way of getting
many o to work on the command line
or, like, with a single URL.
So the URL references is kind of just
a a locator
for words replicating to. Okay. So it part
it it notices that there's local host reference
in there, and then it extracts everything before
that to get the bucket name.
Okay. Got it. I could I'm that means
I'm not gonna lose any sleep tonight now
because I was definitely worried about losing sleep.
No. Yeah. Because there's a couple of like,
other services like I think it's either Digital
Ocean or Linode or
Backblaze.
Like, they use some convention where they use
sub domains as your bucket.
So with that kind of stuff, kinda follows
that same convention, but here, it's really more
PAC. So
Okay.
So we can wrap Actually Sorry. I need
to go. Before you before you run that,
I would add a dash v
at the beginning.
Yeah. Just you can get a little more
information.
Just it's just for robust logging. So let's
see what's going on.
Yeah. So
runs pretty fast,
but, yeah, basically, it pulls a snapshot down
and puts it in, like, a temp location
next to the file where it's gonna go
to.
It'll download
the wall files in parallel and then apply
them in order as they come through.
And then finally, once everything's applied and the
database is in the state it's supposed to
be in, then is when it finally renames
it to the final destination
so you don't get it's
kinda like an atomic restore. So you're never
gonna get, like, a partially restored database
and your in the location you wanna go
to or the the destination path.
So that's what it's doing there.
Okay. So we should now have
first d b two. Yeah. Yeah. First two.
Yeah. So you can see the light into
that now.
Should be all there.
And there it is. Yeah. Cherry Road. There
you go. Software just shouldn't be this easy
to use.
I honestly, like, a big
like, I really try to focus on just
narrowing the the feature set to just, like,
the simplest. Like, if there's anything moderately complex,
I'd I'd just wait to try to implement
that until I can find a simple way
to do it. But
I don't want people to have to read
their, like, pages and pages of docs and,
like, figure out weird concepts or debug things.
It's mainly because I don't wanna debug issues.
But, really, it's just, you know essentially, it's
just a snapshot and there's a series of
wallpages that it's saving.
So right. If you think about it logically
like that, it's a lot easier to think
about.
Awesome.
No. I think that's that's pretty sweet. Like,
hopefully, you know, the peoples that are watching,
you can see just how easy it is
to to connect Litestream to SQLite.
The backup process,
because less than a few minutes, the restore
process was even faster.
And then I guess at that point, you
know, as long as you've got an s
three compatible storage that, you know, you trust,
like s three, GCS, something like that. Got
pretty sweet SQLite production resilient database setup. What
more can people ask for?
Exactly. That's what I'm always saying.
Alright. Yeah. No. I think it's a I
think it's a honestly, a great way, you
know, people can
I think I think SQLite is really a
great database? Like, I think people should definitely
consider production use cases.
And I think the way that I think
about it personally
isn't, like, should I use SQLite,
but more like,
should I use I kinda default with SQLite
as kind of the the database I wanna
use. It's just a lot easier to develop
with and test with.
And then I kind of if there's a
reason to use something different like Postgres, then
I'll I'll use that, but I kinda default
with SQLite personally.
Yeah. I I definitely something that's a lot
more appealing to me these days. You know,
I'm quite deep into the cloud native Kubernetes
ecosystem now and storage is still the the
biggest pain point there because
you're having to either learn new database technologies
that are built to be replicated by default
or, you know, you're trying to shoehorn this
kind of behavior and or really get that
tight feedback loop with backup and restore and
minimize that, you know, you talked about it,
the checkpoint snapshot in time, but minimize that
window of where really bad things can happen.
And SQLite's a really nice way where I
can just have a fail on a disk,
use Litestream as a sidecar container, have it
replicate and backing up to
somewhere that I trust and I don't have
to manage. I'm happy to pay whoever
sends it as per meg for that or
gig.
Yeah. It's just really And
then you talked about future stuff and you're
like, oh, well, you should be able to
have live
read only replicas of this data as well.
So not only if I got my application
run-in with SQLite, but I've got scalable copy
of it to a certain degree with the
read replicas.
Yeah. Yeah. And also on the, you know,
the replication side. Oh, sorry. On the replication
side, it's like it's not even just necessarily
have a ton of rights, but I don't
if you ever look at, like, JAMstack where
people will generate out all their pages instead
of content and put them on CDNs.
So you get super low latency at the
edge, but it really works well as, an
edge database if you wanna a server, you
know, The US, but you also have another
another replica in Europe and Asia, wherever you
want, where those you know, those people are
getting those super low latency queries as well.
I just have an idea, and you're gonna
hate it or maybe love it. I'm not
sure now.
But can Litestream compel to WASM?
I haven't tried it yet, but maybe. I'm
not sure what the SQL support is
and go for WASM, but we brought the
shot probably. Might be able swap out the
SQL lite or implementation
for, SQL JS or something. Yeah. I wonder
if you could compare this to WASM, have
a web interface for modifying static data that
actually replicates that in the browser to an
s s three compatible store. I think that
would be really nice.
Why?
Well, why not? Yeah.
Exactly.
Okay. We got a couple more comments from
Rio there. So
that was exactly my use case I was
thinking of. Hopefully, you mean cluster API. If
so, that's really cool. I'll share links to
the videos where I actually got that working.
And
another one about the local hosting.
Currently startup local host does work on Linux,
at least, they say on Fedora.
I could add an entries to host file
for no reason then for years. So I'm
I'm gonna be playing with that later.
Right.
And is there anything
that we didn't cover from a documentation that
you wanna run through before we we we
wrap up today?
No. I don't think so. The only thing
I would say is, yeah, we have a
a pretty active Slack community.
If everybody has questions and needs help getting
up and running, drop on there, and we're
happy to help.
Obviously, you know, GitHub if you wanna post
issues.
And then I do office hours every Friday
too. So if anybody ever wants to chat
live, I'm happy to chat. So just hit
me up. You can find the link on
the website as well.
Alright. And I'm ben b johnson on Twitter,
so you can usually find me there too.
Yes.
There is the Slack link here. Get involved
with this big button here too. Yeah. Go
do that. I have the office hours. I
know. I took out the the yeah. Anyway,
well, just hit me up. I'll we got
office hours.
We'll join the Slack, and Ben will share
the office hours link with you as well.
I'm sure. There you go. There you go.
Definitely.
Your Twitter handle is on the screen. Definitely
fun to follow you and see all the
weird, silly things you're doing with database.
I used to say silly. It's now it's
borderline genius, think, to a certain degree. Like
so
Thank you. It's a fine line, I think.
Alright. Well, thank you very much for working
on Litestream. I'm already seeing so many different
applications for cluster APIs. The the one I'm
really focused on right now, but I
maybe I'll get some time to stream some
Wasm stuff with it and see if we
can do something stupid there too. But thank
you so much for for joining me today,
getting us through this and sharing your experience.
Any last words? Yeah. Thanks for having me
on. No. Thanks for having me on. It's
been great. I'm glad everything that seemed to
just work, so that's awesome.
And, yeah,
happy to chat. Thanks. Awesome. Well, have a
great day. I'll speak to you again soon,
and thanks for watching everyone. Cool. Bye. Have
a good one.